okay last episode we kill Marie as she
was hiding a secret let's see what the
secret is the [ __ ] is this place oh god
there's something over there doesn't
look nice hi hi hi there okay let's see
what we can find in this lovely lovely
lovely village better Oreo or what the
[ __ ] is in there know what this is but I
don't trust it
[ __ ] Merlotte's I don't know how they
manage to create more disgusting places
like Jesus Christ oh my god what that
[ __ ] ah what was that
don't give up [ __ ] you don't tell me
what to do
okay now I'm fighting you two
[ __ ] me oh there's a [ __ ] what is
this a good idea I don't I don't I don't
fit Oh God Oh oh Jesus Christ he scared
me
ah come on i'ma [ __ ] this [ __ ] man I
[ __ ] you
No okay good good
well you're ugly Jesus Christ that's
[ __ ] are you Oh God
no don't bite my face off [ __ ] you
sharks [ __ ] you I'm out [ __ ] out
[ __ ] this there you go Oh God never mind
no don't you [ __ ] dare touch me do
you like Oreos ow
I can't [ __ ] see what the [ __ ] is
going no no don't touch me don't touch
me [ __ ]
disgusting trash goddamn I hate those
you just know the boss fight of this
area is gonna be the ugliest [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever and I say that in a nice oh my
god stop stop
who's doing that [ __ ] sake Morris are
you [ __ ] kidding me
ah give me a break what how did it get
shark man hit me up there
oh my god not this [ __ ] [ __ ] again
the shark oh god the shark is here
Plan B everyone okay here we go oh god
what the [ __ ]
Nerva sharks I hate them someone tell
the shark man to shield the [ __ ] out
awesome [ __ ] awesome [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you and your [ __ ] shark you [ __ ]
shark [ __ ]
look at the [ __ ] spear inside me
right in my hahaha
hey hey not another one Jesus Christ I
don't like getting pierced catch Thanks
I didn't mean with your [ __ ] body
Jesus
oh this is awkward we have the same
weapon - nice dress buddy
oh there's two of them three of them
okay I miss a party or something
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you oh it's over your time
yeah that's right they're kneeling to
the Sun oh god boss battle five time yep
yep [ __ ] call that [ __ ]
what is that that looks like skin
Oh
all right what you got me
out out out
where the [ __ ] is he
Oh God
oh that could have been it come on come
on and you're dead [ __ ] you really fun
bus battles in this game I'm just so
focused I don't know I enjoy it more if
I just focus and take it for what it is
I know it's not as entertaining I just
got to be more though [ __ ] all right
I'm gonna kill all your kids now I bet
they're super bummed that you died how's
it going doing your daddy best of your
daddy
I might be crazy but okay now it works
now it works
I don't know what the [ __ ] I did wrong
hey may you like my new outfit
it's from Abraham Bree and Fitch or
whatever the [ __ ] people wear okay here
we go
final boss
he's bared looking as awkward as mine
it's great man Lawrence you look skinny
Wow I understand I hate being waking up
when I'm taking naps - this is some
[ __ ] he's like I have the worst
[ __ ] headache man why the [ __ ] I'm so
hungover the [ __ ] did you wake me up man
why oh great oh it's like cleric beast
Oh God there's a lot of damage hey man
if you want to help out yeah feel free
man
holy [ __ ] has a lot of health
that's just awesome
by arrests is that worth it
third stage what do we got
what that [ __ ]
come on
whoa what
we're almost done it again
there's so much [ __ ] damage
oh god no just [ __ ] wrecked in a
second it's not [ __ ] fair [ __ ] you
and your [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
no [ __ ] you
yeah [ __ ] me again [ __ ] me again a
[ __ ] dare you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] god damn it what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] [ __ ] hate that a
[ __ ] dick [ __ ] every [ __ ] second
god damn [ __ ] what the boy hate that can
you stop hitting me yeah I'm so sick of
you you [ __ ] banks oh my god
oh my god [ __ ] off
look I mean lava look everyone look [ __ ]
you I said fun buffoon
you're funny to have Lafite QQ turbine
hen lavetta's job la vita
come on
Thanks [ __ ] you
I think I almost broke the game for a
while I think I almost broke for a while
that was [ __ ] ridiculous I wasn't
like that was an exciting fight or
anything you had to [ __ ] DPS for like
10 minutes and then you go to the final
part and then the final part is just one
big [ __ ] [ __ ] fest he just swings his
arm where that was an optional last boss
of the DLC thank you for watching I
might do more videos I know I'm super
pissed right now but still I love
blood-borne I think it's my favorite
game it's such you get it lost in the
world so easily when you play it and you
get so invested in it that's why I I
don't know maybe you you think it's
crazy I'm [ __ ] pissed I get it but
you're so into while playing this game
and that's how you know it's actually a
good game I really really love that I
can play this game for YouTube and for
you for you bros it's a lot of fun so
thank you for watching I'll end it here
I didn't crying thanks for watching
Walter you sir